attaining
so the history of this work uh which is
in collaboration with my uh colleague
and uh my academic brother muhammad ali
zadeh who is that
at mit
this is primarily work of three graduate
students abdullah puya and aarash in
collaboration with aneesh this is the
preprint
uh now the way it started is
2020 december which is in the middle of
pandemic for my brother-in-law's wedding
i was in india in delhi in a hotel
and i was stuck there and
mama then i was supposed to write a
paragraph for one of those big nsf
grants
and it realized that neither he or i had
done our work so he called me saying
let's write a paragraph together
and i was saying we should do something
about causal inference and he was saying
we should do something about network
systems
and that beautifully led to this
collaboration and lots of uh
interesting projects that have come out
of this
um
of course the grant did not get funded
but it did the work
uh so that's the most important reason
why we should write proposals um just
paragraphs all right so with that
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
briefly explain one of the setups in
which we're trying to build a network
simulator for simulating what would
happen to the outcomes of network
communication network
quantities
in a trace driven manner and i will make
i'll make it precise what it means and
the system that comes out of it is
causal sim it's a
the
the work is both uh methodical and there
is a lot of empirical work so i will try
to do justice to both to the extent i
can in the time i have
all right so here is a simple question
um
all of us see uh and consume video
content online these days in all forms
be it netflix be uh
zoom or anything else at the end of the
day there is some video player that you
have on your device
that's constantly talking to a server
sitting in cloud
and asking it to send it data to play
the next part of the video okay and
on one hand
ideally the server wants to get your
player wants to get as much data as
possible so that it gives you as high
quality experience as possible on the
other end if network conditions are poor
by the time the data that you asked
arrives
it might be too late and you might have
this jittery experience
so how do you balance this jitter on one
hand
thank you
so by the time
the data comes back to your player you
want to make sure that uh you have uh
enough playback time available okay so
it's always a balance between this and
the whole goal of a good abr protocol is
to make sure that it constantly keeps
adapting to this situation
all right so just to make it a little
bit more precise roughly speaking the
way uh this algorithm or this protocol
works is as follows there is some notion
of let's say decision step t
at that time you have some amount of
time worth of video
video content is already available okay
so this is the amount of time you can go
without having any more data
so that's good higher it is you can be
more aggressive and ask for more data
for the or higher quality things lower
it is you should be in trouble because
soon you will start experiencing the the
jittery things
so at some level your protocol now
chooses some rate rate determines the
how much amount of
data that will come back to you from the
server
okay and then
there's a network condition unknown of
course
hopefully not changing drastically but
that will determine some effective
throughput so
this is the amount of time it will take
for that data that you asked for it to
reach
you had this much of buffer that's gone
okay
and of course the each decision cycle
roughly speaking corresponds to t
amounts of
time worth of
video play
okay so this is how roughly the dynamics
revolves
and of course if you
if it took too long and if you ran out
of course you ran out
questions
ct is dividing the s or the
yeah so
ct is my rate yeah so uh st is the
number of bits i want
and then i divide it by ct so that will
be the amount of time it took me
to get that content from the server and
by the time that much amount of time i
used my existing buffer to play
so now my buffer has shrunk but then it
increased once it reached
and if you're
if you're a person if you have seen
queuing uh this is like a queue
so far so good
and again question is what is the best
protocol and if you think from
reinforcement learning perspective this
is uh one way to think about this is a
nice reinforcement learning problem
but with partial observation i'll i'll
hint on that
in a bit
so
if one has to ask this question and if
you're a causal inference workshop
you'll say well just run randomized
control trial
so
you have
five different protocols that you really
think are great candidate
and then now you go and deploy them in
wild
okay and every time you have to sort of
run a video stream you choose one of
them at random across people across time
and all that and then sort of see the
performance and then based on that
design
this sounds
daunting challenging
turns out uh there's a
group at stanford
uh did uh go ahead and do it this is
either the yan ir zoo foldy hong zhang
levis and
keith weinstein they did this uh
experiment uh from august 2020 till may
2021
uh it was a collection of client servers
set up across the
country
in different data centers and uh cloud
environment and then that through that
they have collected this data set called
buffer
okay
there and five um
abi protocols
um
it corresponds roughly to
four years worth of video so if you got
that video and you started watching
today without blinking your eyes forever
then it will take four years so it's a
reasonable amount
and they measured all sorts of things
these are just few things i'm uh i'm
reporting okay so it's a very very nice
uh
experiment it still continues to go on
uh we're gonna sort of look at use this
data
and that's it
all right so what's the question well
now i have my own protocol that's called
fabulous abr
okay now i want to try it i want to
compare it with those five things
so one option is i can again go back and
run for
uh one and a half years and see what
happens
and maybe now sort of instead of five at
six so maybe my time should increase by
uh six by five
okay
um and so on so clearly this is
expensive
so maybe alternative would be
you say well why not
try to
use the same protocol but on the traces
that you have collected
so i have collected traces under five
protocols historically under buffer data
set
i'll go back and i will run effectively
now those or simulate those stresses
under the sequence of actions that i
will take as my algorithm
now of course there are a few challenges
so let's see what are those challenges
um now
before i sort of fully erase the
challenges here are a few
approaches that i'm going to put out one
is
naturally the obvious approach is say
let's do supervised learning
well i observed historical data
i know
every aspect of dynamics that i could
observe so from there let me come up
with a model of dynamics
and then learn it supervise learn it and
then
so we would use a nice neural network
for that
another is since i had laid out this
dynamics clearly for you and i'm an
expert i'm just going to use this
that is for
every time step t
i knew what was the realized throughput
what was the action i had taken and
that's how buffer changed
if i changed my action
of course throughput will remain the
same and i will sort of now evolve my
buffer differently
okay that's all
and then the third one which is the
method i want to discuss i'll do that in
a bit
okay uh
now
one question is sort of when you have a
data set like this okay let me pause
this for a second um if you have a setup
like this question is that how do we
evaluate
how do we evaluate that whatever method
we have is doing good or bad
because i don't have the counterfactual
right
remember i had five protocols and each
protocol was assigned
one of the streams to uh play
at random
so if you believe in rct
then effectively what it says is that
the type of network correct
characteristics that each of the
protocol we will see in a distribution
sense should be the same
so maybe we should look for certain
distribution characteristics
of protocol
and then see if it does well
putting it another way if
here is what we are going to do
so we have
five policies
okay
let's say one of the policy in the data
that i have uh i will call it my
fabulous abr policy that i want to
simulate and i'm going to take all of
its data out
yeah
basically something about the
application so yes
so
imagine i measured on i measured the
c hat
sequence and you have measured
so imagine i have understood the
distribution of sequences of c hats yes
is that enough information to validate
anything i want or not is there a
feedback loop between what they are
probably abusing and the c art that i'm
seeing also literally
so in this case it's something in
between but that's exactly the problem
and that's what one needs more than
supervised learning so if
c hat
was not impacted in some sense by my
action
then this is it
but
in in reality does get impacted
and i think that's basically the issue
that is so question is that what is that
and how does one account for that
thank you
perfect question
please feel free to stop me
okay so um
so what are we going to do uh there is
one policy whose data we're going to
just withhold okay uh there's another
policy let's call it target in this data
set let's call it bba it's one policy
uh so i've got a bunch of traces under
under it i'm going to use them
as a source so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take these traces
and over which i'm going to run my
policy and see what the outcomes look
like okay and then the policy would be
supervised learning the
the
the expert simulator and then causal
symbol i'll describe uh uh soon
and then what i will do is i will try to
measure performance in terms of
distribution of buffer occupancy
so distribution of buffer occupancy
under
the
simulated
policy that i have
and the actual data that i have and
hopefully
they should match they should match if
my simulation is good if my simulation
is not good that won't match
so here is um
result in the nutshell nutshell so this
is cdf okay
and this is a buffer occupancy in
seconds
uh
the withheld data set
which is this which is actually this
pink dashed line
okay
the training data set or rather the data
set on which from which we altered is
this black dash line and as you can see
black dash and
pink are different
which means these are sort of two
different policy outcomes understandably
and what you really ideally want is
uh
if good simulator you have it would
causally transport it from this to that
okay
uh the green method that we have causal
sim actually does that uh at least
visually does that well here uh the blue
one is the expert sim
and the red one is the
the supervised line
and so what this shows is that
these guys are trying to simulate the
the
training or source policies that you
already had versus causal sim somehow
figures out how to transport it okay so
in a nutshell it has to correct for
something that's hidden something that
is compounded there
okay and that's basically uh
all that's happening behind the scene
right so what is that confounder so the
confounder actually is the true network
throughput
so imagine that
i asked my network to send me a data at
one kilobits per second
and network send me the data at one
kilobits per second
but maybe network capacity at that time
was one megabit per second
just because i saw it at one kilobits
per second doesn't mean it's actually
one kilobits per second
and that's basically what's happening
that is when you see the observed
throughput you don't know uh what is the
real capacity
and if you could then potentially you
would be able to figure that out and
this is uh exactly what's happening
that
bba the observed throughput is like this
under
fab abr because we have the data the uh
the
observed throughput look like this now
observed throughput are
not the network latent network condition
right
network condition if good rct is done
they should be same
of course we don't know that
but observed are different because the
policies are different
all right so now that i've told you at
least uh
the issue in a nutshell let's try to
sort of model it and let's say sort of
how this model will help us come up with
a solution
so here's a simple um
uh dynamical systems model that uh that
we'll use
so
at each time step we take an action
and action in this context is deciding
how much
data to obtain for this each chunk
this is my observed uh buffer occupancy
my observed state
my action
uh impacts my
realized throughput
because if i ask for one kilobit it's
going to give me one kilobit if i ask
for more it will give me more and
there's a latent network uh capacity
which i could realize so these two
things determine what my observed
throughput is
and observe throughput along with my
action and along with my previous buffer
occupants it determines my new buffer
occupancy
so this is my model in a nutshell
any questions
again other than
gray everything is observed
now
in the spirit of
scm is basically
one way to represent this dynamics is to
say that well there is some function
a function of action and this latent
state which determines this my
intermediate mediator which i observe i
don't observe u but i observe a
i don't know the function
and then i've got some other function
that maps my
previous state this mediator and then
the action to give me the next state
all right so this is happening at some
instant in time yes
now the latent variables across time
they're changing yeah so ut ut plus one
you two plus i'm gonna assume that
they're exogenous and so they may also
be
uh unbounded so are you assuming any
independence between them or so i'm
assuming that
these are given to me because
uh i'm as one abr decision maker i'm um
i'm a drop in an ocean so my making
decision is not going to change my
network's condition but it will
definitely impact my realized throughput
so they may be
correlated amongst themselves as they
like but they're
for you
so i'm really interested in saying that
let me go back to the same that instance
assuming the same network capacity
available to me
and let me change these things there's
no stationarity
i'm just giving it
but
this is an assumption
right so and just setting the question
in the context of the data we had so
we've got
and trajectories collected over key
protocols under our city setting
a trajectory i that says some length of
steps
for each time step we observe these
things
these are my related things
now simulation would say
that
instead of these sequence of actions
i've got some other sequence of actions
starting with the original buffer
occupancy let's call it o0
now sequentially simulate it so that i
can get four twiddles
and while i'm getting four twiddles of
course in the intermediate setting i
will get amp twiddles too
yeah so this was the m this was my
buffer this was my
action and this was my network latent
network capacity
so in a sense this is my unobserved
confounder which is
so at this stage i'm saying actions are
just given to me
and i just want to now change the
actions because i got this model
okay so now let's see sort of how one
would go about this
so at least
there are two functions right there's
the f and g
well these things i observe and let's
assume that i observe things enough
and there's enough diversity so that i
can do supervised learning so maybe i'll
be able to learn g
okay so that's not a problem
uh but
now i need to know am twiddle
to know m twiddle
um i need to know f
um so m twiddle is function of a and u i
don't know u i don't know f
so
the problem is am twiddle if i knew
somehow m2l then i'm done right
because then i will take the amp twiddle
i will learn g
i'll just plug it in i'll do this
sequentially and i'm done
so really the whole problem is mtwiddle
okay with that
so
okay so let's write m as this it's a
function of
two variables
uh if function is nice
it's a
nice continuous function
lip sheets and let's say that the
actions and confounders themselves in
some latent representation if not actual
they're coming from some compact domain
then they would
they would have some kind of singular
value decomposition
which would effectively look uh
low rank okay let me posit this
okay if you
don't like it let's say this is i'm
positing this and we'll verify for the
data and all that
but if we believe into this
then one way to look at my problem is
this i've got those actions on
rows
i've got columns which are my
unknown u's
and
the entries are my m's
and this m is some uh
some factor associated with action and
some factor associated with uh
with confounders and then just inner
product of that
so maybe
effectively i've got now to do amp
twiddle i need to do low rank
matrix completion potentially
so let's see how that looks like
let me take super simple example let's
say i've got just two actions
okay and now i've got a number of
confounders and as um
you correctly point out
for every
trajectory and every time instance there
is a separate u so if i clearly i'm
stacking up all of those things lots of
them
okay so this is like really really
really uh wide matrix
okay
and the data would look something like
this right
because there are
just without loss of generality output
some of them i would observe in first
row and exactly for the other columns i
would observe the second row
and i want to find this out
and let's assume to keep things super
simple it's rank 1 matrix
but still i can't solve this right
so
something got to give
there's something that we have not
utilized that we utilize to solve this
problem
um
and okay i've got a few more
three more minutes maybe
no no
it's the end of the day
it's a bad karma problems at some point
open problem
but bad karma uh okay so here is uh the
thing we have not utilized that the this
data came from randomized control trial
if it came from a randomized control
trial and okay um this is not exactly uh
you know really think of this as a
policies in that setting but let's think
of simply actions
okay so then
the
distribution of
confounders
that got action one
should be
similar to distribution of confounders
that got action two
in particular the first moment of
the latent factors of this should be
same as the first moment of latent
factors here
which means that i can take average of
this green
average of these greens take the ratios
that should give the ratios of the
factors associated with these two things
for rank one
so that solves my rank one problem
if i have a higher rank problem i need a
little bit more i need more measurements
so one way to do that more measurement
just stack it up so then it will look
like a
tensor
okay
you would need that the measurement
dimension is higher than the cp rank of
the tensor
you will need the randomized assignment
you need some coverage
so that you can solve appropriate linear
equations
but you do that and you will be able to
solve this problem precisely
now of course if you're going to build a
system you're not going to do this right
so what you'll do instead is something
like this
okay so there is a
there is a discriminator that you will
use to make sure that you impose the
fact that you know from a randomized
control trial that
confounders that you will find across
trajectories and time steps have similar
distribution across policies
there is a factorization
and then there's a function that you
learn
which takes these things to estimate
your next step
and here you would have the quadratic
loss we used there here we are using the
the typical discrimination laws coming
from the
the
relative entropy
coming to the question of abr uh does it
have low rank now see uh
in the
since we don't have counterfactuals i
cannot evaluate the rank
uh mama and his group have been working
on this question for uh close to uh
more than five years now it started with
this beautiful work here
uh
pensive actually it's uh
pretty actively utilized out there in
practice
and that was evaluated based on um a
trace given
expert simulated that build and for that
simulator uh we do this uh proper
uh
look at the right slices and then sort
of do the evaluation it turns out to be
at least 99 of energy is captured by
top two components
let's see i've got maybe two minutes
okay
now you can sort of use this simulator
so dig the data simulator on simulator
you can uh train the policies and all
that and
shuttle along is that um
it does actually help you improve quite
a bit in terms of
effective
quality of
service or how as a viewer you find it
um
there are other problems like load
balancing
so if
um
any reasonable system that's designed
right now um will have
a good load balancer load balance will
have jobs coming and jobs assigning to
servers you don't know what are the
service rates you don't know what are
the job sizes
again put it through the similar uh
setting
the effective uh quantity of interest
which is time it takes for a job to
finish on a server is actually rank one
matrix there
and
similar thing that happens there as well
um
there you could sort of actually have an
interpretation of latent factors uh
captured by the
the
the system they were actually
corresponds should correspond to job
size and they do
um
all right so
ending now in the last 30 seconds
see here what we have done is we
utilized among other structural
assumptions that many of the works in
this
in the broadly panel data setting folks
have utilized is the low rank tensor
structure is this
uh structure induce or property or
invariance induced by randomized
controlled trials and now if i look at
that and so if one goes back to the
traditional population level randomized
control trial where there's an
individual
who is giving a one specific treatment
and now observed bunch of measurements
for that individual
i only observe that individual under
one
[Music]
one intervention but if this
observational tensor or matrix looked
had a low rank
then with this invariance
potentially i would be able to do
individual level
treatment effect evaluation and i think
that's something
really exciting
all right with that let me stop
[Music]
so again um
uh for load balancing again in a very
similar manner you have sort of
different policies
different policies determine
given the incoming jobs which servers
they assigned to based on the state of
the network
and then
every time a job comes you randomly
decide which policy you're going to use
for example or you run the whole trace
under one of the policies but at random
you need for the tensor estimation like
is it relate to uh because of
distributional
[Music]
so actually
in all of this discussion i ignored the
observational noise but even to just
learn the latent factors
i will need um let's say the i will need
to match the moments of the underlying
latent factors across different actions
so that i can solve i'll generate enough
that's a system of linear equations so
to speak so that i can solve them
thank you
there should be refreshments waiting for
us outside and then
we'll be